hi everyone welcome to the simplyland
youtube channel
this session will be about golang for
beginners before we begin let me inform
you about the daily updates on multiple
technologies on our channel if you love
hunt for technological stuff consider
getting subscribing to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit the bell
icon to never miss an update
we from simplyland bring you this
beautifully designed organized and
upgraded colling course for beginners
for 2022.
now let's start with today's agenda
and confirm me whether am i audible or
not by commenting in the comment section
so first we'll start with the
introduction to the golang programming
language
following we will learn to install
golang on windows and to write our first
program in calling after that we'll
start with the basic conception going
moving on we will educate ourselves with
go interface followed by go concurrency
and afterwards we'll have an
introduction to co-length grpc
with the topics covered till now we can
have a comparison between golang and
python
finally we will be implementing golang
by developing the go best api
go also known as golang is an open
source programming language developed by
google
it is a statically typed compiled
language
moreover go supports concurrent
programming that is it allows running
multiple processes simultaneously
this is achieved using channels go
routines etc
go language has garbage collection which
does memory management and allows the
deferred execution of functions
it also supports networked and
multi-core computing
you can run your first code without any
setup on the playground provided at
colland.org
we will look into the history of golang
the gop programming language was born
due to the complexity of managing the
infrastructure and code bases within
google
the language creators all from google
had a clear goal design a programming
language that would be easy to use but
still be able to cover the main
challenges while working with the
company's intricate systems
go was designed by robert christmer
roe pike and ken thompson
and was designed at google in 2007 and
was announced to the public in 2009 and
it was made open source in 2012 with the
release of version 1.0
the most remarkable release that is
golang 1.5 was presented in august 2015
and it included considerable changes the
compiler tool chain has been converted
from c to go entirely and at this stage
golang took the form to which its
authors aspired
now we will be knowing why to learn
golang
first reason that is easy to use and
learn golang is easy to use and
understand it has gained popularity in
the top 20 programming languages
go has a linear learning curve that
appeals to novice programmers
if someone already has hands-on c sharp
or c plus
learning go for them should be more
accessible due to its striking
similarities to c
the next point we consider is community
and documentation
you can find the documentation on the
official website that is
golang.org
go has solid and easy to read
documentation apart from documentation
go also has a supportive and active
community
you can use the hashtag golank whenever
got stuck on twitter to reach out to the
community
impressive standard library
go users have a standard library packed
with the language which reduces
importing complex secondary libraries
goes standard library is vast but not
confusing that is without the issue of
conflicting function names
one of go's best contributions to
programming is
it offers a more straightforward way of
integrating data structures into code
blocks
next reason to learn golang is strong
security
simple code is safe and more secure than
complicated code as go is a statically
typed language go users don't have to
debug a lot of errors
which is the case with many dynamic
languages and their number of variable
types
plus the inclusion of a garbage
collector
also helps prevent memory leaks
and the last reason to learn golang is
attractive wages
according to a survey conducted by
stackoverflow co-developers are the
third highest paid after pearl and scala
due to goes increasing popularity every
year this figure will continue to rise
now we'll look into the features offered
by golem
first that is flexible
because of the language design and its
roots from c
colang is easy to learn and understand
with simple syntax
next concurrency
go allows multiple processes to run
simultaneously its ability to take
advantage of multi-core processor
architectures
and efficient memory is one of the
reasons
why gocode is today running some of the
most heavily used applications that can
scale
next is the fast output
go comes with a very quick compilation
time
in the golang development environment
there is no virtual machine the code is
directly compiled to machine code making
the compilation process faster and more
effective
besides the compiler produces only one
executable file after compilation
this file does not suffer from
dependency and can be uploaded and run
anywhere this makes the code execution
process faster
the next is library
go comes with a powerful standard
library
distributed as packages which also
reduces importing complex secondary
libraries
the next feature is
garbage collection this is goes one of
the key features it controls memory
allocation and has significantly reduced
latency in the newer versions
developers
need not worry about freeing up pointers
or the situation associated with
dangling pointers
now we'll see the uses of colon
go was originally built for programs
related to networking and infrastructure
intended to replace popular
high-performance server-side languages
like java and c-plus plus
kolang's support for concurrency makes
it an excellent choice for handling
bottlenecks that prevent scalability
today go is used for a variety of
applications
who is popular for cloud-based or
server-side applications
concurrency and networking features
align with its high portability across
various platforms make go an exceptional
language for cloud computing
as a matter of fact many standout cloud
platforms like kubernetes are built with
co google cloud also uses co to enhance
scalability and performance
devops and site reliability automation
are also popular ways to use co
many command line tools are written in
go
also go is used in the world of
artificial intelligence and data science
some uses go for microcontroller
programming robotics and games
go shines the most when it comes to
infrastructure today some of the most
popular infrastructure tools are written
in go such as kubernetes docker and
prometheus
now we'll see some popular ids used by
golang programmers
goland
colend is an ide by jetbrains to provide
an ergonomic environment for goal
development
sublime text
it is a commercial source code editor
that supports many programming languages
and markup languages
you have to install go sublime plugin
through package control that provides go
code completion and other ide like
features
go clips it is an eclipse extension that
adds id functionality for the go
programming language
vimgo
vim is often called a programmer's
editor
plugins adds go language support for web
visual studio code using the go
extension for visual studio code you get
features like intellisense code
navigation symbol search
testing debugging and many more that
will help you in core development
you can install the go extension from
the vs code marketplace
now we'll see some companies using
golang
uber
a ride-hailing platform that uses go
within its microservices
kubernetes kubernetes is an open source
container orchestration system used to
automate software deployment scaling and
management
google designed kubernetes but the cloud
native computing foundation currently
maintains it
dropbox dropbox is a file hosting
service that has migrated some major
components from python to go
netflix netflix is the most popular ot
platform and has used go to develop its
server architecture
twitch which is a live video streaming
platform that uses core for many busiest
systems
soundcloud
it uses go to perform static analysis in
real time which is possible due to
static typing and fast compilation
in this session we will go through a
brief introduction to the golang
language
after knowing the basics we'll get to
know about variables data types and
operators in the language further you
will learn about loops supported by the
go link
and you will know how to declare the
functions and pointers in golang
finally you learn about the packages
we'll look into what is collag
go is a strong and statically typed
compiled language
strong language depicts that the type of
variable cannot change in a code it will
remain the same throughout the code here
statically typed means all the variables
must be declared at compile time
and compile language states that you
only have to compile the code
and it will be converted to machine code
directly it is same as c or c plus plus
go doesn't have a virtual machine like
java language
which takes time to convert the script
into machine code
moreover core supports concurrent
programming that is it allows running
multiple processes simultaneously
this is achieved using channels go
routines etc
these features help code to improve its
performance
companies such as google twitch and uber
use go for their micro services
technologies like docker kubernetes are
developed in the go language
we'll go to the official website of go
for that we'll move to google chrome
and search for golank
this is the official website for go that
is code.dev
here we can see the mascot of go
language this is the blue mascot
as we scroll down we can see the
companies using gold language
go is called the minimalistic language
as it has very little documentation
it is easy to learn as it has fewer
features and less confusing parts as
compared to java
here
you can run your first code without any
setup on the playground
we will run hello world
here we will write hello
world and click on the
run button
it will send the code to the server for
compilation and we will get the output
that is hello world
we can download the golang
from here we will click on the download
button
and here we can see we have download
options for microsoft windows apple mac
os linux and we have the source file
i have downloaded for the windows as i
have the windows system
but from downloading go you also have to
download an idle to run the code
for that i have downloaded and installed
vs code
it's up to you
but ideally you want to choose
now we will learn about variables in
golem
a variable is a storage area defined to
store temporary data and perform
operations on them
moreover variable values can further be
changed according to program needs
variables declared without any
corresponding value
are considered zero valued
there are mainly two ways to declare
variables in co-link that is using where
keyword and using short variable
declaration
let's move to vs code and see the
declarations live
now we will open a new file and see how
to declare variables in golem
and we'll use the inbuilt terminal of vs
code
here we'll select the language
as go
and press enter
the first thing we'll do is import fmt
for that we'll write import
and in what is comma we will write fmp
that is a formatting package and it
contains the print function
everything in golang is inside packages
whether it is a print function or any
other function
use packages by using import and writing
the package name in inverted commas that
is import inverted commas fmt
if someone wants to use your script
he can by importing your go file or your
go package
so it becomes mandatory in golang to put
the code in a package here we will put a
code under the package main
so
we will write
package
main
we will declare a main function in which
we will write our code
we will write
func func and the name of the function
as main
round brackets
and we'll start the curly braces
and inside these curly braces we'll
write our code
we will declare a variable
to declare a variable first we need to
write the name of the variable second
type of the variable and then the data
assigned to the variable
for that we will write
where keyword
name of the variable we will keep it as
a and then the type of the variable that
would be end
and will assign the value
7
we will declare another variable
that is
b
where keyword
name of the variable as b and the data
type end
and we'll assign the value 96
now we want to print these variables for
that we have imported the fmt package
for that we will write the command fmt
dot
println
a comma
b
for that
first we will save the file
we will
name the file as demo
demo dot co
and now
we will run the command in the terminal
go
run
demo dot go
and press enter
here we can see the output that is 7 and
96
that is we have successfully printed
both the variables that is a and b
we can also declare the variables
in different form
like
we can write
variable keyword
and if we want to declare two variables
we can declare them in the same line
for that we will write
variable t comma
e and the data type that would be end
and in the next line
we will assign the values to them d
comma e
equal to
7 comma
21.
now we will print these variables
for that we'll write the command
save the file
and run the same command in the terminal
that is go run demo.co
and press enter
we can see the output that is 7 96 and
721
now we'll see another method that is
short variable declaration method
for that we'll just write the name of
the variable
that is v
colon equal to
and the value that we want to assign to
this variable
we will assign 76
it is same as the previous method that
is variable the name of the variable
data type and the
assigned value
now we'll also get this variable printed
for that we'll write the command fmt dot
println
in circular brackets we will write the
name of the variable
we will save the file
and then the same command
in the terminal that is core and demo
dot go
we will traverse to the next topic that
is data types in golang
data types specify the type and space
allotted to variables or functions
there are four categories of data types
in golang
that is bool type
it represents a boolean value and is
either true or false the next is numeric
type
it represents integer types floating
point values and complex types
the next is string it represents a
string value
and we have the derived types it
includes pointer types array types
structure types and many more
see some demonstrations in the vs code
first we will see the float type
we have seen the integer type in the
previous example of variables
now we will
add
two float numbers and print the output
for that
first we will declare the float number
that would be
96.28 and we will declare another
variable that is slot variable
and assign a value that would be 18.09
now
we will declare another variable
as the output variable
and will store both the variables
by adding them
now
we'll print the c variable
that is the output variable
we'll save the file
and run the command in the terminal that
is corondemo.com
we can see the output that is 114.37
it shows
that
both the float values have been added
now we will see another data type
that would be string
first will clear all the code that you
have written
now we will declare a string variable
str
colon equal to
and we will write
simply learn as a string
and we'll print the string
fmt dot
println
str
now we'll save the file
and run the command in the terminal that
is core and demo dot go
here we can see that the simply learn
string has been printed
now we will move to the boolean data
types
for that we will use the same code only
and we will declare
another string
that would be
string one
and we'll store
string
learn in it
and now
we will compare both the strings
we will declare another variable
that is out
and in this we will compare both the
strings
and we will print the variable out
we will save the file
and then the same command that is core
and demo note go in the terminal
here we can find that output is false
because the string str it contains the
string simply learn and the string str1
it contains the string learn
so we are comparing
both the strings and they do not
fall same
so it gives the output as false
now we will traverse to the next topic
that is operators in golang
an operator is a specified operation
that is performed on the operands
in the following list describe the
different operators used in golang
first is arithmetic operators
it includes addition subtraction
multiplication division and modulus
let's see some example
in the vs code
first
we will
erase all the previous code
and we will declare two variables to
perform operations on them
we will declare variable a
and assign the value 96 to it
and another variable
sorry
declare another variable
that is p
colon equal to
that is 18
and now we will perform different
operations on them
first we'll
perform addition
we will declare another variable that is
out
and we will store
both the variables
by adding them
and print the out variable
and save the file
here we got the output as 114 that is
addition of both the variables
we will perform next operation that is
subtraction
for that we will declare another
variable
that is out one
and perform the operation as a minus b
and we'll
print the variable out one
we'll save the file
and then the same command
go run demo dot co
here we can see the output as 78 that is
96 minus 18
now we will
perform another operation that is
multiplication on both the variables for
that will declare another variable that
is out to
and print the
variable out to
will save the
file and then the same command in the
terminal
and we have find out that the output we
got is 1728 that is the multiplication
of both the numbers 96 and 18.
i will perform another operation that is
division
and for that we will declare another
variable that is out three
and will perform a
divided by b
and we print the variable fmt dot
println
the variable is
out three will save the file and the
same command in the terminal
and we would find 5
that is the output of the variable
out 3
that is we have divided 96 by 18.
now let's see the last operation in the
arithmetic operators
that is modulus operator with that will
declare another variable that is out 4
and will perform the operation a modulus
b
and will
print the variable out for
will save the file
and run the command in the terminal
we got our output s6
now
we'll see some relational operators
that would be equal to not equal to
greater than less than
greater than equal to or less than equal
to
for that
first we will clear the variable
out
and we'll perform another operation
that would be a
is it equal to equal to
b
we'll save the file
and run the command go run demo dot go
what we find is false
because both the variables have been
assigned different values that is 96 and
18
so they're not equal
we'll perform another operation
that would be
a
not equal to
b
let's save the file
and run the command in the terminal
here we got true
as the output because both the variables
have been assigned different values and
they are not equal
we will perform another operation that
is less than
for that will clear the previous
operation
and we will write the operation
whether
a is less than b
or not
we'll save the file
and run the same command go run demo
note 4
we have come across the output as false
as
the operation is a less than b
but a holds the value 96 which is
greater than b
so it gives the output as false
now we will move to logical operators
logical operators consist of logical and
logical or and logical note
we will see the example of logical and
for that
we will write the statement
if
a is not equal to b logical and
a is greater than equal to b
and if the statement is true we would
print out
fmt dot
println yes
we'll save the file
run the command in the terminal
here you can see that we got the output
as yes
it means
that a is not equal to b
that is 96 is not equal to 18 and 96 is
greater than equal to 18.
so this is the logical and operator
now
we will see bitwise operators
bitwise operators consist of bitwise and
bitwise ore bitwise or
left shift right shift
and note
we'll see an example of bitwise end
for that
we will declare a variable
that would be
ar
o
and we will perform bitwise and
on a and b
and we will
print the result
that is
arrow variable
and save the file
and run the command go run demo.com
here we find out that
it gives the output as
so what does bitwise and operator do
it takes
both the numbers 96 and 18
and perform and on every bit of both the
numbers
and the result of end is one only if
both bits are one
now we'll move to another operator that
is assignment operator
it consists of various operations that
is single assignment
add assignment subtract assignment
multiply assignment to each an
assignment
modulus assignment with twice and
assignment
bitwise exclusive or be twice inclusive
or
we will see an example
of
simple assignment
for that we will just
write the statement
a
simple assignment that is equal to
b
and print the variable a
let's save the file
and run the command in the terminal
here we can see that
the value of the variable a has changed
and it has turned out to be 18
because
we have
used the
simple assignment operator
now we will traverse to the next topic
that is
loops in golem
a loop is the repetition of a block of
code that executes a control statement
specific number of times
go language works with a single loop
that is for loop
and moreover core language uses for loop
in various forms
such as infinite loops
for loop as while loop and using four
loops four strings and maps
we will see a simple example to print
simply length string seven times
for that will move to vs code
and clear all the previous data
and start with the for loop
4
and initializing the variable i
that is i equal to 0
semicolon
i
less than 7
i plus plus
curly braces
and now i will write the statement
to print simply learn
now we'll save this code
and run the command
the terminal go run demo dot go here we
can see that we have printed simplyland
seven times
we will traverse to the next topic that
is function in golem
a function is defined to execute tasks
by writing blocks of board
it reduces the excessive use of memory
with the reuse of the code
in golang we declare a function by
one keyword followed by the name of the
function with parenthesis
and then a block containing the code
now we'll see the syntax of the function
first we'll write the func
keyword
then we'll write the function name
and the parameters for the function
after that we'll write the return type
and in curly process we'll write the
function body
golang also contains a special feature
that is anonymous function
we will see a simple example of
multiplication function
that would be defined by us
and it would get two arguments in that
for that we'll move to vs code
and we'll erase this
for loop
now we'll declare a multiplication
function
outside the main function
here
first we will write the fun keyword
then the name of the function
that we will write multi
and then we'll pass the
arguments
t comma e
and
assign their data type
and the return type
of the function
and then we'll start with the
curly braces
and here
we will declare a variable
that would be out
and it will perform the operation of
multiplication
and will
return
the variable out
and inside the main function
we will
declare
two variables
a equal to 76
and
b equal to 91
and now
we will declare another variable
that would be d
and in d we would call the
function that is multi
and pass both a and b
as arguments into it
and
print
the variable d
we will save the file
and run the command
currentdemo.com
we have got the output as 69166
as the multiplication of 76 and 91.
now we'll move to the next topic that is
pointers in golden
pointers are considered as special
variables in golem
pointers are used to store the memory
address of another variable
the memory address is stored in a
hexadecimal format starting with 0x like
0x
a f etc
now we will see an example of pointers
in collec
for that we will move to vs code and
clear out the previous code
now we will declare a variable value
and assign
value 96 to it
and now we will declare another variable
mainly a pointer variable
and now
in this variable
we will store the address
variable value
now
we will print
the value
that is stored
in the variable value
and the next we would be displaying
is the address of value
that is m percent
of value
and now
we will
display the value stored in variable
a
now we will save the
program and run the command go run demo
dot go
in the terminal
here
we have got the output value equal to 96
that is we have printed the value stored
in the variable value
and the next we have displayed is the
address
of the variable value
that is ampersand value
and we have stored the address in
variable a also
and that's also been displayed
in the next step
so now we will traverse to the next
topic
that is packages in golang
as we have already discussed packages in
the beginning now will overview about it
a bit
packages are directory containing
various methods functions and large
number of programs related to particular
functionality
it makes these large programs easy to
maintain and understand and help in
distinguishing them of the other package
programs
to import package in a go program we can
use import path
as we have seen in the
examples we have done so far
in this session you will learn what are
interfaces and how to create an
interface
after this you will learn about empty
interface
further you will get to know about type
assertion and type switch let's start
with what is an interface
the key principle of an interface in go
is to provide method signatures for
similar types of objects
go does not have classes and inheritance
to implement object orientation
go has the interface and abstract type
to fulfill this purpose
for example
motor vehicle can be an interface with
method signature mileage
any type which provides definition for
miles method is said to implement the
motor vehicle interface
let's learn how to create an interface
in go you can create an interface using
the type keyword
followed by the name of the interface
and the keyword interface
and you can specify method signatures
inside curly braces
you will get to understand the creation
of interfaces with example let's move to
visual studio code and create an
interface
i have opened a file and named it
interface dot co
here we will just create the interface
for that we'll first type the keyword
type
then the interface name we will
name it as moto vehicle
and then type the keyword interface
we will start the curly braces
and inside we can define method
signatures
we will define
mileage
as a method and it would be of
return type plot
and we will declare another method that
would be average speed
and
that would be your type string
now we will see how to implement an
interface in go
to implement an interface in go you need
to implement all the methods declared in
the interface
go interfaces are implemented implicitly
unlike java you don't need to explicitly
specify
using the implements keyword
in the previous program we have defined
the motor vehicle interface which has
two methods mileage and average speed
that return float64 value
any type that implements these methods
will also implement the motor vehicle
interface
now let's look at a practical use of the
interface
we will write a simple program in the
visual studio code
that would calculate the total mileage
for a person based on the individual
mileage of his cars
for gravity we have assumed that
distance covered is in kilometer and
fuel used will be in later
so let's move to visual studio code
and start writing the program
first we'll write package main
then we will import fmt
and now
we will declare our interface that would
be
type
the name of the interface that is motor
vehicle
and the keyword interface
we'll start the curly braces and declare
our first method that would be mileage
and it has
a return type
plot
64.
we have two cars owned by the person bmw
and od defined by struct names
so first we will define the struct
for the card
bmw and od
for that we will write type
bmw
and it is struct type
inside the curly braces
we will define distance
that would be of type
plot
64
and that is average speed
and that would be of the type
string
now we have declared
let's declare and the struct type that
is od
for that we'll write type
od
struct and inside the curly braces we
will define distance
as the return type float64
and the fuel consumed
with the same type float64
now
to implement the motor vehicle interface
we need that the bmw struct and the od
struct
should implement
the method mileage for that we will
define the method mileage for both of
them
first we'll declare the method mileage
for bmw
for that we'll write function
bmw
that would return the type as
float
64.
and we have to declare the method that
is mileage
and inside the curly braces we will
define this function that would return
ether distance
divided by
b dot
fuel consumed
we have declared the method mileage for
bmw
now we will declare for the type
od struct
for that we'll write function
ode method name that is
mileage
and it would also return
float64
so this would be small
and inside the curly braces
it would also return
the distance traveled by the od that
would be a distance
divided by the fuel consumed by od
now we'll also define a function that
would calculate
total mileage like both the mileages of
bmw and od in a month
for that we will declare method total
mileage
for that we'll write
func
total mileage
and this the total mileage function will
take a slice of motor vehicle interface
as a parameter
so for that
inside the
circle brackets
we will pass
a struct
of the interface motor vehicle
and inside the curry process
first we will define a variable in which
we will store the total mileage
for that will declare tm as the variable
and is its initial value would be 0.0
as it would return the type float 64.
now
we'll run our loop
and pass a slice that contains both bmw
and od types to the total mileage
function
the total mileage function will
calculate the total mileage in the
variable tm by calling the mileage
method of both the corresponding types
so we will define
range
m
and inside the curly braces
we will
add up the mileage
and we will get it print
out
that would be fmt dot
print
f
total mileage per month
that is a float type
and it is in kilometer per liter
and it is stored in the value
tm
now we will define the function main
so first we will
assign the values for the struct type
bmw
for that we will
assign the values in the variable
v1
distance would be
167.
kilometers covered
coma
fuel consumed
would be
36 liters
coma
and the average speed
for bmw would be
would be 58
and we have declared the average speed
as the type string so
we will
make 58 in the inverted commas
now
we will declare a variable
a1
for the type body
and store the values for the type struct
od
distance covert would be
152.9 kilometers
and the fuel consumption
would be 30 liters
i forgot to put the comma here
yeah
so now
we will declare a person
variable
who possess this both the cars and he
wants to calculate the mileage of both
the cars in a month
so here we will pass the slice
motor vehicle
and inside the curly braces we will pass
both the variables p1 and a1
and call the method
total mileage
and pass
person variable in it
we'll save the code and run the code in
the terminal
so that will open the new terminal
and write the command
go run and the file name that is
interface
dot go
press enter
here we can find the output that is
total mileage per month is nine point
seven six zero five five six kilometer
per liter
now we have learned how to implement the
go interface
let's move to another branch that is
empty interface
when an interface has zero methods it is
called an empty interface
this is represented by interface and the
curly braces
since the empty interface has zero
methods all types implement this
interface implicitly
better understanding we will understand
the empty interface with the help of an
example
we will move to visual studio code and
create another file and name it as empty
interface
dot go
and in this
file we would see an example
how to implement an empty interface
for that
we'll write
package main
and import the package
fmt
now we will declare a variable
i for the interface
and just
make the curly braces
now we will declare a function
found
and pass the interface
and inside the curly braces
we will find
the type and the value of different
types
which
would be implementing the empty
interface
for that we'll write
fmt
dot
printf
the type
equal to percent t
comma
and the value of the type
percent v
slash n
in function main we would declare the
types which would implement the
interface
that is an empty interface
for that we will write
function main
starting of the curly braces and first
we'll declare a variable s
and inside will store a string that
would be simply learn
and call the method found
and we'll pass the variable s in it
we will run this code for that
first we'll save the file that is ctrl s
and now we'll run the command go run
empty interface dot go
press enter here we can see that the
output is type equal to string and the
value stored in it is simply learned
instead the string type has implemented
the empty interface
now we can declare
more types
that can implement the empty interface
we will declare a variable that would be
i and it would
store an integer value that would be 7
and we'll pass this variable into the
method found
now we'll save the program
and run the file again
here we can find that the type equal to
end and the value stored
as the end type is 7 so it's clear that
as many types can implement the empty
interface
we'll move to the next topic that is
type assertion
type assertion you can find the dynamic
value of an interface using the syntax i
dot type
where
i is a variable of type interface and
type is a type that implements the
interface
understand the type insertion with the
help of an example for that we will move
to the visual studio code and
see the interface dot co file
here we have the average speed
declared in the struck bmw
we will declare a method
that would be average speed
for that will write
function
b
bmw the method name
that would be average
speed
and it has the return type string
that would come in front of the function
name
and inside the curly braces
we will define the function
it would return the value average speed
now if we want to get the average speed
of bmw
printed we won't be able to do that
we can see in the total mileage function
we would print fmt dot
printf
m dot
average speed
as the interface motor vehicle it has
only a single method that is mileage
it can't access the average speed of the
struct type bmw
so it won't be able to
print the average speed
this is where type assertion comes into
play
type assertion lets us extract the value
of the underlying type that is bmw here
and then it will call the methods on the
return value that is m
in order to do that we have to make a
type assertion of the underlying type
that is bmw
of that interface
once we are able to do this we can
extract the value and store it in a
variable and then we can call the
methods on that variable because now
that variable has type and value equal
to underlying type
and value of the interface
for that
first we will copy this code
and create a new file type
assertion dot co
and
paste the code in the new file
now
now we will clear the function total
mileage
and declare a variable a u
we will extract out the value in the
variable a u only for that we will write
m dot and in the parenthesis we'll write
bmw here m is the variable at which we
are making an assertion about
it would be followed by the period and
in parenthesis
we will place the underlying type of
that interface
the go program does not see this
parameter
as bmw
it sees it as a motor vehicle interface
now the underlying value has been
extracted in the variable au we can call
all of the methods of bmw by simply
putting in the print line function first
we'll declare the print line function
for that will write fmt dot printf
and we will call the average method
that is
a u dot average
speed
and now
we will pass the bmw struct
that would be declared in the variable
b1 so we will erase
this
and
we don't
need the slice here
and in total mileage we would be passing
the b1 variable
we will save the file
and
run in the terminal
here we got 58 as the output that is we
have passed average speed
as a string and that has the value 58
now we have understood the
implementation of type assertion
we will move to learn the next topic
that is type switch
in type switch you get the dynamic type
of the interface instead of the dynamic
value
with syntax like
type assertion
that is idol type where i is a variable
of type interface and type is a type
that implements the interface
type switch is similar to creating
multiple else statements in code
we would understand this with the help
of an example
for that we will create a new file
that would be
type switch dot go
in this type switch example we would
define an empty interface and
we would declare different types that
would be implementing this empty
interface
with the help of type switch
for that we will write
package
main
we will import the fmt package
we will declare a function
named like
we'll write function
like
and pass the empty interface with the
variable i
now we will write
switch i dot type
in the curly braces
and it specifies a type switch
switch
i dot
in the parenthesis
type
and now we will define different case
statements and compare the concrete type
of i to a specific type if any case
matches the corresponding statement will
be printed first
we will define a case
that would have string as a type
and
if the value matches with the
type string it would print the statement
i
learn at
percent s
for the next line we would write slash n
and the variable
i dot
string type
we will pass different types in the
function like in the function main if
any case matches the corresponding
statement would be printed the next case
would be
it will have the integer type
and
it would print
so p would be capital
okay
period printf
and in the
circle brackets we would write
about the age
i am
percent d
years
old
for the next line we have
inserted slash n
and will pass the variable i dot
int
now
if
the value doesn't matches with these
cases we would define a default
print statement
that would be of empty dot printf
and the circle brackets would write
unknown type
now we will come to the function main
in the function like
first we'll pass a string value
that would be simply learn
and we'll call the like function again
and pass an integer value
and
we will pass
and float value that would be 12.89
now
oh sorry
12.89
now i'll save the code
it's showing an error
okay we didn't
define the curly braces here
okay
p is more of printf
okay now we'll save the file
and run in the terminal go run
type switch.com
in the output we can see that we have
printed the statement i learn at
simplylearn and i am 27 year olds and
the unknown type so we have first pass
the value that is simply learn it
matches with the
value string and it printed the
statement i learned it simply learn the
next value we passed is in type and it
matches with the case end and it print
it i am 27 year old
and next we have passed a float value
and we didn't have any case for the
float value so it printed the unknown
type
now we are clear with the type switch
in this session we will learn about what
concordance is
and how parallelism is different from
concurrency
after this you will learn about
concurrency in go
you will get to know go supports
concurrency with core routines and
channels
here we will take a dig at knowing go
routines
and their properties
further we will learn about channels
let's start with what is concurrency
concurrency is a process that deals with
loads of activities operating
simultaneously
let's understand the concept with the
help of an example
let's consider a person driving a car
while driving he feels hungry and
reaches a drive-through and collects a
food parcel he holds his car into a
parking lot eats the food and heads to
his home here the person is capable of
performing both the action
simultaneously that is having his food
while driving but he performs actions in
a sequence this is concurrency
moving on we will understand how
parallelism is different from
concurrency
both parallelism and concurrency produce
the same result but with different
approaches parallelism is the process to
perform various actions simultaneously
particularly not in sequential order
let's understand parallelism with the
help of an example discussed during
concurrency
let's assume the person is driving the
car and simultaneously eating the food
in this scenario the person performs
both actions simultaneously that is
parallel
this is parallelism
parallelism doesn't always result in
faster execution time in parallelism
actions are performed parallelly in
multiple course creating the need for
components to communicate with each
other
where concurrent systems have a low
communication overhead
now understanding the differences we
will head to understand concurrency in
go
popular programming languages like
python and java use thread pools to
execute concurrency
whereas go has built-in features go
routines and channels to achieve
concurrency
go routines are much easier to manage
than thread pools that are purely
operated by the operating system
go works on the communicating sequential
processes
csp concurrency model
now we will understand how go routines
and channels operate in concurrency
model
first we'll head with go routines
a go routine is a function that executes
concurrently with other functions or go
routines
go routines work in the background while
the main part of your program goes on to
do something else
go routines are not os threats
to work with go routine you have to
prefix the go keyword to the function or
method a go routine is a lightweight
thread managed by the go runtime
now we'll understand the usage of
coroutine with the help of an example
first we will go through the properties
of go routines
every program consists of at least one
go routine and that go routine is known
as the main go routine
go routines are deeply integrated with
go's run time goes runtime monitors go
routine behavior suspends them when they
become blocked and then presumes as they
are unblocked
go routines are inexpensive compared to
threads they possess only a few kb in
stack size
and the stack can expand and contract
according to the application whereas the
stack size is fixed in the case of
threads
now we'll understand the go routines
with the help of an example
here in this example we would be
passing 11 and 77 as a string to the
function number
and then printing it
with the loop seven times
so here inside the package main we will
declare a function number
and pass a string to it inside the
function number will run a loop seven
times and print the path string
to print we have imported fmt package
now in the function main we will call
number function and pass 11 and 77s
string
we will save the file
here i have saved the file with the name
concurrency.co
and we will open the terminal
and run the file with the command go run
and then the file name
we have to make sure to perform this
operation in the same directory where
the go file is saved
here
we will write the command go
run and then the file name that is
concurrency
dot go and press enter
we can see
that we got the output as 11 and 77
seven times each
in the main function press the control
will be shifted to the
number function where we pass 11 it will
get executed and then the control will
come back
to the main function and then the
control will be shifted to the function
number
when we pass
77 to it it will get executed
and print 77 seven times now the control
will be shifted to the main function
and the program terminates as there are
no other lines of code to execute in
main function now we will be
implementing go routine
for that we will use the prefix go
before the function number
we'll write the go keyword before the
function number
we will pass the string 11
and we'll save the file
and run the command in the terminal go
run concurrency.go and press enter
here we can see
only 77 as the output would get printed
seven times
we have released a thread
go
but never waited for it to come back
that's why we have only voted
the output at 77.
to get the code thread executed we'll
use the sleep method in a program
for that we will write
time
don't sleep
and inside the
circle brackets
we will
mention the time for one second
for that we have to import the package
time
now we will save the file
and run it
here we have used the sleep method in a
program through time package that will
help the main go routine sleep for one
second
and in between one second the new go
routine executes
the space 11 has output and then
terminates after one second the main
core routine reschedules and performs
its operation
we can see the output
11 77 11 77 77 11 77 and goes on
now we are done with the example let's
move to channels
go routines communicate with other
elements through channels
panels can be thought of as a passage
through which go routines communicate
the channel is defined using the make
function and the chain keyword each
channel has a specified type defined
with it
this type of data is only allowed to be
transported by the channel
the zero value of a channel is nil and
they are not of any use until defined
channels are designed to prevent race
conditions when assessing shared memory
using core routines
in this session you will learn about
what grpc is
next you will learn about the grpc basic
concepts you will get to know when the
grpc is used and further you will learn
about the strengths and weaknesses of
grpc
and moreover we will learn about the
companies using grpc
let's start with what grpc is
grpc is an open source framework that
handles rpc that is remote procedure
calls and helps build scalable and fast
apis it allows the client and server
applications to communicate
transparently and help developers
develop connected systems
this framework works on http slash 2
protocol buffers and other modern
technology stacks to ensure maximum api
security performance and scalability
next
we will learn about the grpc basic
concepts
that is
protocol buffers
streaming
http slash 2
and channels
let's understand these concepts in
elaboration
first one we'll start with protocol
buffers
protocol buffers or protobuf is google's
serialization or deserialization
protocol
it is used as
interface definition language idl and
serialization toolset by grpc both the
client and server should have the latest
and same protofi
grpc stores your data and function
contracts in the form of protofites
protoc that is the protobuf compiler
generates client and server code using
that dot protofile
it loads the
code using the dot protofile
into the memory at runtime and uses the
in-memory schema to serialize or
deserialize the binary message
you can exchange the data faster with
protobuf as it requires fewer cpu
resources since data is converted into
binary format and encoded messages are
smaller in size
the next concept we have is streaming
streaming is another key concept of grpc
where many processes can take place in a
single request
the multiplexing capability that is
sending multiple responses or receiving
multiple requests together or a single
tcp connection
of http slash 2 makes it possible
now we'll see through the types of
streaming the first one is server
streaming our pcs the client sends a
single request to the server and
receives back a stream of data sequences
that is server streaming rpcs the next
is client streaming offices the client
sends a stream of data or sequences to
the server which then processes and
returns a single response to the client
that is client streaming offices the
next we have is bi-directional streaming
rpgs it is two-way streaming where both
client and server send a sequence of
messages to each other without failing
for a response
now we will move to another concept that
is http slash 2.
it is another key concept of grpc in a
traditional http protocol sending
multiple requests or getting multiple
responses together in a single
connection was impossible a new
connection will need to be created for
each of them
this kind of request for response
multiplexing is made possible in http
slash 2 by introducing a new layer
called binary framing
and bi-directional streaming was
possible full-fledged with the
introduction of http slash 2. the next
concept we'll move on is channels
channels are another key concept the
http slash 2 streams allow many
simultaneous streams on one connection
channels extend this concept by
supporting multiple streams or multiple
concurrent connections they provide a
way to connect to the grpc server on a
specified address and port and are used
in creating a client stuff
now you will understand the grpc
architecture
in the following grpc architecture
diagram we have the grpc client and
server sides in grpc every client server
has a grp system the grpc client makes
the local procedure call to the stub
with parameters
that to be sent to the server the client
stub then serializes the parameters with
the marshalling process using protobuf
and forwards the request to the local
client time library in the local machine
the os makes a call to the remote server
machine via http slash 2 protocol the
servers os receives the packets and
calls the server step procedure which
decodes the received parameters and
executes the respective procedure
invocation using protobuf the server
stub then sends back the encoded
response to the client transport layer
the client stub gets back the result
message and unpacks the return
parameters and the execution returns to
the caller
moving on
we'll learn when to use grpc
grpc is used in real-time communication
services where you deal with streaming
calls
and it's used when efficient
communication is a goal
and it's used in multi-language
environments and moreover it is used in
internal apis where you don't have to
force technology choices on clients
and it's also used in new builds as part
of transforming the existing rpc api
let's see grpc strengths which has
increased the adoption on the old rpc
design methods
the first one is performance
by different evaluations grpc differs up
to 10 times faster performance and api
security than rest plus json
communication
as it uses protobuf and http slash 2.
additionally protobuf serializes the
message on the server and client sides
resulting in small and compact message
payloads satp slash 2 scales up the
performance ranking via server push
multiplexing and header compression
server push enables http slash 2 to push
content from server to client before
requesting while multiplexing eliminates
head of the line blocking http slash 2
uses a more advanced compression method
to make the messages smaller resulting
in faster loading
the next one we have is built-in
community features
grpc provides built-in support for
commodity features such as metadata
exchange encryption authentication
deadline or timeouts and cancellations
it also provides load balancing service
discovery and many more
now we'll see another strength that is
streaming
grpc makes it much simpler to build
streaming services or clients a grpc
service supports
different streaming combinations through
http slash 2 which we have seen earlier
that is client to server streaming
server to client streaming or
bi-directional streaming
the next is security the use of http
slash 2 or the tls that is end-to-end
encryption connection
in grpc and shows api security grpc
encourages the use of ssl or tls to
authenticate and encrypts data exchanged
between the client and server
now we have known the strengths of grpc
now you need to be aware of some points
before choosing grpc for developing
applications these points may affect
your decision of using grpc
the first one we'll see
is limited browser support as grpc
heavily uses http slash 2 it is
impossible to call a grpc service from a
web browser directly
no modern browser provides the control
needed over web requests to support a
grpc client therefore a proxy layer and
grpc web are required to perform
conversions between http 1.1 and http
slash 2.
the next is steeper learning curve
many teams find grpc challenging to
learn
they get familiar with protobuf and look
for tools to deal with http slash to
friction it is a common reason why users
prefer to rely on rest for as long as
possible
the next is non-human readable format
protobuf compresses grpc messages into a
non-human readable format this compiler
needs the messages interface description
in the file to deserialize correctly so
developers need additional tools like
the grpc command line tool to analyze
protobuf payloads on the wire
and they also write manual requests and
perform debugging the next is no edge
caching while http supports mediators
for edge caching grpc poles use the post
method which is a threat to api security
the responses can't be cached through
intermediaries moreover the grpc
specification doesn't make any
provisions and even indicates the wish
for cache semantics between server and
client
the next is limited community support
the community support for specific
technology can be a big consideration
for its adoption
with minimal developer support outside
of google and not many tools created for
http slash 2 and protocol buffers the
community lacks information about best
practices
this is changing the developers coming
in and adopting grpc the next we'll see
is the companies using grpc the first
it is an american multinational
technology company that focuses on
artificial intelligence search engine
technology online advertising cloud
computing computer software quantum
computing e-commerce and consumer
electronics the next company that uses
grpc is ibm that is international
business machines corporation it's an
american multinational technology
corporation headquartered in new york
with operations in over 171 countries
the next one that uses grpc is netflix
it's an american subscription streaming
service and production company it was
launched in 1997. it offers a film and
television series library through
distribution deals as well as its own
production that is known as netflix
originals
the next company that uses grpc is cisco
it's also an american multinational
technology
and it's located in california the next
one we have is dropbox it's a file
hosting service operated by the american
company dropbox incorporation it's also
headquartered in u.s that is san
francisco california it offers cloud
storage file synchronization personal
cloud and client software in this
session
we will go through a brief introduction
to both the languages golang and python
after knowing both the languages we will
compare them on various parameters
further we will discuss disadvantages of
both the languages
now we will look into what is co-link
go also known as golang is an open
source programming language developed by
google co-programming language was born
due to the complexity of managing the
infrastructure and code bases within
google
go was designed by robert grismer rob
pike and ken thompson
it is a statically typed compiled
language
not only that go supports concurrent
programming that is it allows running
multiple processes simultaneously
this is achieved using channels go
routines etc
and moreover you can run your first code
without any setup on the playground
provided at golang.org
now
let's get an introduction about what is
python
python
it is a popular in
general purpose programming language
with straightforward syntax
python was developed by guido van rossum
in 1989 and was released in 1991.
python's name was taken from the popular
bbc comedy show
monty python's flying circus
now
we are familiar with both the languages
let's get down to comparing them
we will compare both the languages on
various parameters
firstly we will compare on the parameter
paradigm
go is a multi-paradigm programming
language it is procedural functional and
concurrent language
whereas python supports four main
programming paradigms that is imperative
functional procedural and object
oriented
let's compare the two on the topic of
performance
when we talk about performance go is
fast the performance is similar to that
of java or c plus
go is 40 times faster than python
to have a check we will compare the
performance of the languages by solving
three complex problems that is the
mandelbrot equation and body problem and
binary
it is to evaluate memory usage and time
spent to solve the problem we have
chosen these three problems as
they are considered the best way to test
the memory management and performance of
the language
here you can see the stats of both the
languages
you can see that collag takes 6.23
seconds and uses 30 108 units of memory
whereas the python takes 253
point 19 seconds
and sixty thousand four hundred ten
units of memory to solve the mandelbrot
problem
binary tree problem go takes
29.02 seconds and uses
four lakh ninety eight thousand one
hundred sixty units of memory
whereas the python takes seventy nine
point zero three seconds and uses four
lakh forty seven thousand three hundred
twenty four units of memory to solve the
problem
for n body problem go takes 23.5 seconds
and uses
1641 units of memory whereas the python
takes
765.34 seconds
and uses
7944 units of memory to solve this
problem
this clearly shows
that golang has outperformed python when
it comes to performance
let's compare the two on the topic of
scalability
the whole purpose of developing golang
was scalability
this is why golang has
inbuilt support for concurrent process
channeling that is concurrency
on the other hand python has a hard time
with concurrency but it can execute
parallelism through threats
let's understand the concept of
concurrency and parallelism
concurrency means that an application
runs more than one task simultaneously
but only one upfront and rest in the
background if the computer possesses one
cpu
the application may not progress on
multiple tasks simultaneously but more
than one task is processed inside the
application
it does not finish one task before it
begins the next
you can see the plot of concurrency here
here different tasks are running but
only one is running at the front and
others are running in the background
now we move to parallelism
parallelism means that an application
runs its task into smaller tasks that
can be processed in parallel that is on
multiple cpu simultaneously
let's see an example of a team of
technicians building a monitor
concurrency allows multiple technicians
building different parts of the monitor
but they share one common workbench for
assembling the parts
only one technician can assemble at the
workbench at a time and other
technicians operate on their parts in
the background
with parallelism
you can have multiple workbenches
where technicians can be building parts
simultaneously
so it's obvious that a language has
support for concurrency it is perfect
for big and scalable programs
let's move ahead and compare these two
languages based on their applications
golang is mostly used for systems
programming due to its inherent support
for concurrency golang has also found
ample use and acceptance in cloud
computing and cluster computing
golang has also seen a lot of
recognition
and use in artificial intelligence and
data science
due to its powerful and easy to use
libraries go can set up a web server in
a matter of seconds
go is also used in microcontroller
programming
robotics and games
on the other hand python is widely used
in web development data analytics
artificial intelligence and deep
learning
this can be mostly accredited to the
insane libraries available in python
that make the life in the set fields a
lot easier
let's compare the two on the topic of
execution
now let's understand how go and python
are executed
golang is a statically typed language
whereas python is a dynamically typed
language
both python and golang use interpreter
and compiler respectively
now we will understand what is
statically typed language and
dynamically type language
in a statically typed language
variable types are declared explicitly
for the compiler so that even trivial
bugs are caught easily
whereas in a dynamically typed language
the interpreter implements type
inference hence some bugs may remain
because the interpreter interprets
something incorrectly
it implies that python a dynamically
typed language limits the programmer
when he intends to build a really big
program
at the same time goku can handle both
types of programs
let's get on to the libraries in both
the languages
in golank you would have to write your
code to search through data tables
and if you want to implement machine
learning it would be a huge short to
develop in go
but this doesn't mean golang falls short
in any terms
while developing go google choose the
most important libraries
as a part of their inbuilt co-libraries
we can see here that gom library
it helps in converting data between
incompatible type systems
we can see another library that is cli
it was developed for building command
line apps for go
gokut
it is github's popular library for go
related microservices
authorization boss
it is an easy way to implement
authentication and authorization in your
web systems
while the number may not be as
boisterous as pythons the covered usage
fields are almost identical
they have built-in libraries for web
development database handling concurrent
programming and encryption
yes python is almost 16 years older than
go
which results in much larger community
and online support
the python libraries in particular are
vast exploring data tables can be easily
done with pandas and machine learning is
simple with tensorflow and pytorch
this type of support can get anyone
writing code from the day one now let's
get to the next point of comparison that
is readability
while developing software you will
generally work as a team with tens or
even hundreds of other developers at
such time code readability is the major
factor to consider
golang has strict programming rules it
doesn't allow unnecessary variables to
be defined or unnecessary libraries to
be imported
this implies a definite way to perform a
task leading to a better understanding
of code while working in a team
golang syntax is not friendly to
beginners but
it's not as unforgiving as c or c plus
plus
on the other hand
python sure has fantastic readability
but there are probably 10 different ways
to say the same thing in python
which mostly leads to confusion whenever
the script is big or while working in a
team
we can see a simple example of finding
two numbers that is 7 and 9 in both the
languages in golang there's a definite
way to write a code whereas in python
you can write in different forms but the
readability is really fantastic
now
we will consider memory management as a
next comparison
olen provides with great memory
management whereas
python offers no memory management
which comes in handy while running the
complex problems which we have seen
above while comparing performances
that's it for this comparison for now
now we will look into few drawbacks of
go language
firstly it is not a generic language
till now go does not have any generic
support
this is due to the repetition of codes
for the same type of operations but with
different data types
moreover some data structures cannot be
implemented due to lack of generic
support
next is fewer libraries and frameworks
there are no major frameworks for golang
developers
other languages such as ruby has ruby on
rails python has django and php has
larval
the next drawback is it is still in the
development stage
being in the development stage golem
developers are finding it hard to make
out of its libraries in case of doubt
there isn't much assistance through the
go community or online support
we have looked upon the drawbacks of
co-language now we will look into the
drawbacks of python language
here you can see that it is weak in
mobile computing hence it is not used in
app development
the python uses the underdeveloped and
primitive database access layer
you can also see that there's a absence
of commercial support for python
and as python is dynamic language it
shows more errors at runtime in this
session you will learn to develop a rest
api and then we will perform cred
operations on it so first we will create
a folder
we will name the folder as rest api new
just underscore api underscore new
and inside will open the visual studio
code
for that first we'll open the command
prompt
and write the command
code space period and press enter
make sure
the visual studio code has cooling
support
for that you can go to the extensions
and search for go
install the go extension i've already
done that
now
once you have done this go extension
installed
now click on the view and open the
command palette
and
write the command go colon install slash
update tools
it will open all the tools of the go
you can select them all
and click on the ok
so all the go tools will be installed
now
you can see all the tools have been
successfully installed now we'll create
a new file
that would be main dot go
and we'll start with writing the package
main
we will run a command
go mode
in it
rest underscore
api underscore
new and press enter
now we will run another command
here it's showing that code mode file
already exists
it has already been created now we'll
run another command that is
go mode
tidy
and press enter
now we'll create the function main
and save the file
and now we will import the modules
for that we'll write the command import
around brackets and inside round
brackets
we will
write the modules
that is
encoding
slash
json
the next is
net
slash
http
the next is string conversion
str conv
and another we will
import would be the gorilla mux
for that we will
open the browser
and search gorilla mux in the web
browser
we'll open the website that is
gorilla mugs github.com
and copy the command go get minus you
github dot com slash gorilla slash mugs
and we'll
paste the command in the terminal
press enter
and now we'll import the gorilla mugs
module
for that all right github.com
slash
gorilla
slash max
now in the main function we will write
the command
router
we will initialize it
mux
dot
new router
this function will be executed when we
call our goal application
here we will set up our routers
here we will create the rest api for
employees for that we will create a
struct with the name profile for that
we'll write type
profile
struct
and inside the struct we will
hold information for the employee
profiles
that would be department
it will be of string type
and in json
we use the
backtext
json
and
it would be represented as
department
the next field would be designation
it would also be of the type string
and in json
it would be represented as
designation
and the next field we would get would be
employ
and we will
make it a complex field
for that we will create another struct
that would be
type
user
struct
and inside the struct we would hold the
first name last name and email of the
employee
and in the json format we'll use the
backticks
json
first name
and the next field would be last name
it would also be of the type string
and in json format
it would be represented as the last name
only
the next field would be email
it would also be of the same type string
and in the json format
we will represent
it is email only
now in the profile struct
we will define the employee field as of
the type
user that would be of the type user
struct
and in the json format
we will represent it as employee
we will start the web server in the
function main
for that we will write the command
http
dot listen and serve
in the round brackets
first we will pass the localhost port
number and second thing will pass the
mux router
so we will define our
port number as 5000
so colon
5000
and the next thing we'll pass is the mux
router
we'll set up the new routes so that we
can
operate and perform operations on it
so in the function main only
we'll set a new route
that would be router
dot
handler
function
and inside
first we will declare the path
that is
profiles
and next the function name we would name
the function as add item
and set the http methods as post
you can see that the handle function has
taken the path and the name of the
function
as parameters
now we will declare the
add item function
this add item function is a route
handler and therefore it will take two
parameters
first will be response writer
that would be of the type http
dot response writer and the second
parameter would be the request variable
so let's start with the function add
item
we'll write func
the name of the function that is add
item
and
we will pass
the response writer
that would be
the variable q
http
dot
response writer
and the next variable
that would be the pointer that will
point to the http dot request
so we will declare with the variable r
set up the rest api where we can send
the json data in the request body for
that
we will declare
a new variable in the body of this
function that would be add item
we'll declare the variable new profile
of type profile
choose new decoder
that would be json
dot
new decoder
and in the parameter it would take iodo
trader
that would be
r dot body
and in decode
we will pass the variable where the json
document should be decoded to
that would be the new profile
now we'll send a json object in the
function
that will write
json dot
new encoder
and inside will pass q
dot encode
and will pass profiles in the input this
takes the variable that satisfies the
interface io dot writer
the response writer here satisfies the
io dot writer interface we can pass
queue and then encode in encode we can
pass a value that can be converted to
json we can do this by using a struct
and we have used the struct profiles
we will set up a content type header on
the response
for that we'll write the command
w dot header
dot
set and in the set will pass the key and
the value the key will be the content
type and the value will be the
application slash json
because of content type postman will
know the data is of json type here we
will be using postman to send the
request
so in the set
we will make the key the content type
and the value is application slash json
now let's create a slice and route to
add items in slice
we'll create a slice
that would be
variable
profiles
file
equal to
square brackets
profile
curly braces
now we can add the data to the slice we
can do that by using the append function
which is an inbuilt function
so we will get back to the add item
function
and we'll use the append function here
that would be
profiles
equal to
append
and will pass profiles
and then new profile
let's try and make some requests to our
api
here we will be using postman to make
these requests
so
we'll start the postman
so we'll create a new request
set the request
as post
as we have declared the method as post
and the url we will
enter would be localhost
colon
the port number that is 5000
slash
profiles
now click on the body
and select row
now here in this body will enter the
structs in the json format
for that
first we will define the curly braces
and our first structure was
the property in the stuff was department
we'll set the department as marketing
coma
the next dose designation
colon
designation would be this search
marketer
comma
the next was
to confirm that
employee
and that is of the user type
so employ
and it has
some fields inside it
so we'll declare those
that was first name
we'll make it as adam
last name
we'll make it
as adam heater
and that would be in the inverted commas
comma
and
every left inverted comma
then the next thing was email
and that would be adam
we forgot to build and run our port so
first we will return to visual studio
code
and save the file
and run the command go build
so it's showing an error that is
undefined http dot listen and serve
okay so
he will be kept up for the end
we'll save the file
and run the command again go build
that dot exe file that is executable
file has been created now we will run
this file for that we'll write the
command
period
slash
and the name of the exe file
that is rest underscore
api
underscore new
and press enter
now the
file is running
we'll go back to postman
and click on the send button
here you can see that we got the output
that is department marketing designation
research marketer
and the details of the employee
so it has been posted
so our rest api is working and the
connection has been connected with the
localhost server
5000
now we will be creating
more functions so that we can perform
current operations
the current operations are create read
update and delete
so we'll move back to the visual studio
code
and create more functions
create route handler in the function
main
that would be
router
dot
handle function
and inside the
circle
brackets
we will write the path
that is profiles
and the name of the function
um i will set it as get all profiles
and the method would set it as get
the h would be capital for the handle
function and f
so in this function get all profiles we
would be fetching all the profiles we
would be adding
in a rest api
and we have set the method as get
so that we can get all the profiles we
can fetch all the profiles so now we
will declare the function
get all the profiles
so write
function function name that is
get
all profiles
and inside
this is also route handler function so
it would be taking two parameters the
first one would be the response writer
that would be represented by the
variable queue
and the second parameter would be http
request variable
that would be the r pointer that would
be pointing to the http dot request
so
we will
start with
q variable that
would represent http.responsewriter
comma
r
now the pointer
that would point at http dot request
now inside the function we will send a
json object in the function for that
we would write this command new encoder
for that we'll write json dot
new encoder
and inside
we will pass the queue that would be the
response writer
dot encode
and in code we can pass a value that can
be converted to json
that would be profiles
now we'll set up a content type header
on the response
for that we would write the command
w dot header
sorry that would be q dot header because
the variable is q here
dot set
and inside the set will pass the key and
the value that would be the content type
and the application slash json
so
we would write that
the key would be content
type
and the value would be application slide
json
now we'll save the file
and we will
enter the command control plus c in the
terminal to stop the execution
now save the file again
and run the command go build
and
now we will execute and run the file
rest underscore ap underscore new dot
exe for that we'll write the command
period slash the name of the executive
file now we'll turn to postman
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more we will create a new request
and inside the new request
we will set the http dot request as get
only
and inside the url
we will copy the same url
and click on the send button
here we go
that the array is empty
so we will again go to the post http
request we have to run this request
again because we have stopped the
execution with the command control plus
seen the visual studio code terminal
so
we will click on the send button again
and we can see that the array has been
passed
into the request body
and we have
seen that it has been successfully
passed
now we'll
go to the
get
http request
that would be following the function
get all profiles
now we'll click on the send button
we can see that it has fetched us all
the profiles that has been entered till
now
we will post another profile
so we would be
making some changes
that would be
sales
sale said
and the employment would be
henry case
pete
and hit
scheme would be
and rick is
99 gmail.com
and now we'll pass this request
you can see that it has been
successfully entered
we have passed the request in the
request body and
you can see the output now we'll go to
the get http request
and click on the send button
see that
it has shown all the profiles we have
entered till now
to see in the json format we just have
to change it to json
we can see that
we have entered
the profiles here
so now we will be creating another
function that would be get the profile
by a particular id here we are getting
all the profiles now we'll be
creating a function that would fetch us
a single
profile with a particular id
put that
first we will be creating the route in
the function main
router dot
handle
function
main insight first will pass the path
that would be profiles
coma
the name of the function
we'll set it as get profile
and we'll set the method here as get
only
because we are fetching
the profiles
now
we will add id in this that would
that would be just beside the path
for that we will write
slash
in the curly braces we would write the
particular id
the id we would be searching to get the
profile
close it in inverted commas
and go to function name also
now we would be declaring the function
for that
i'll write the command
function
and then the name of the
function that would be the great profile
that would be function
and inside would pass the same response
writer and the pointer to http dot
request
that would be the variable queue
http dot response writer
comma r
the pointer to http dot request
in the function body first we will get
the id of the post for the profile from
the route parameter
for that
will declare a variable
that would be variable
id
parameter
of the type string
that would be equal to max dot
vrs function and will pass the pointer r
in that that would return us a map
and inside the square bracket
would
make it id
the next thing we have to do is to
convert the string to an integer we can
do this by using the function
ati that is part of the string
conversion package
so we have to import the string
conversion package
that would be str
co and v
now we'll get back to the
function
that is get profile
i will convert the string to integer
so it returns two values one is the
integer and another is error
we'll see
id comma
error
we'll define two variables
and use string conversion
and the function that would be adoi
and pass the variable that is id param
which we have to convert into integer
now
we will check if error is not equal to
nil
if we do not have any error so what we
can do because the function is returning
two values one is integer and another is
error
if it's the error
then it won't win it so we have to
define that
now we'll check the error
for that
we'll write the statement if
error is not equal to nil
so inside this
we would be
writing a command q root
right header
so it would be representing
a number that would be 400.
the error would not been in means that
it has error it would be showing the
error
now w dot
write
inside will pass the slice
on byte
and inside we would write
id could not be converted to integer
now we will also do the error checking
but before that would write the
statement return
so if there's
a error
the
next statements won't get executed
after the error
and we have the w capital for the right
okay
now we will be checking for the errors
if
id is
greater than equal to
length of profiles
here id corresponds to the position in
the slice if it's greater than length
then it's invalid
here we will write no post found in
return so that code below doesn't
get executed
so for that we'll write the statement
if id is greater than equal to
length of profiles
inside
will write two dot right header
it would display the header as 404
and next statement could write would be
q dot right
with the capital w
and inside the round braces
will pass the slice
of white
and inside
we'll write no profile found with
specify id
and now let's get the post at index or
profile at index
for that we'll write profile
profiles
id
and
write it as
en value and the key would be content
type
and now
set the encoder
and pass the response writer q
dot
import
the variable name
profiles
profile
which is a lot
new encoder
or
it won't be in inverted commas
i'll
get them cleared out
now i'll save the file
and write the command ctrl c
now
we'll build the file
now the executable
file has been created
i will run the executable file
now we'll move to postman
and now we'll
enter all the profiles again
then we'll fetch them
we have to enter them again because we
have created and executed the exe file
again
so we have one profile here we will
click on the send button
and we can see that it has been
successfully passed
now
we will get the second profile
and we'll click on the send button
we can see that
we have passed
two profiles
now
we will get on the get http request
so it if we click on the send button it
will get us
both the profiles and if you want to see
them in the json format
you can see that
we have
got both profiles
now we'll create another
request that would be get
and the same http url
and
after
profiles we have to
make it slash and make it as id 0
to get the id 0 and we'll click on the
send button
and we can see that
the first
profile we have entered was marketing
about the marketer
research marketer
and we have put that
if you want to fetch this next profile
that would be the
index one
you click on the send button
we got that profile that is sales head
in the sales department
that was the second profile
so now
we would move to another function that
would be update
for that we would create another route
and that you would be creating in the
function main only
that will
copy
and paste it
we'll get the function name as update
profile
and the method
that would be put
so in capital letters
now
we will declare the function
you will copy the same function that
would be
function get profile
and make some changes in that only
and paste the function
first will
change the name of the function that
would be
update profile
and we'll be passing the same parameters
here
we would delete
this part
and now we'll create a variable
updated profile to hold the decoded data
we will pass the json document that
would be r dot body and end the code
will pass the address where we want to
store the decoded data
so for that
first we will declare the variable that
would be update profile
it would be of the type profile
and
you will be doing json dot new decoder
and inside we will be passing the
i o dot writer that would be
r dot body
dot
d code
and here we will be passing the address
we want to store the decoded data
that would be ampersand
update profiles
now to update the profile value we will
do
files
id
equal to updated profile
that is update profile
now we'll send it to response
that would be
first we will set the header q dot
header
dot set
and inside we will be passing the key
and the value
that would be content type
and the value would be application slash
json
now
we would be
send it to response for that we will
write the command json dot
new encoder
and inside will be passing the response
writer that is q
dot encode
we would be capital of the n code
and inside would be passing the variable
where you want to store the updated data
that is update profile
now save the file
and in the terminal we will write the
command ctrl c to stop the execution
now we will build the file
now the executable file has been created
now we'll run the executable file
and move to postman
here we will create a new request
that would be of the type put
but before proceeding with that
we have to again enter the profiles
we have one profile already in the
request bodies
so click on the send button here we can
see that it has been passed successfully
now we'll also run again
the get all profiles you can see that we
have one profile and in the json format
now
we will come to the request that would
be of the port type
and copy the url
and paste it here and it also has a
parameter id
so for that we will
write the id as zero because we only
have
one profile that is at the index of zero
and we will
copy the request
body and click on body click on draw
of the type json
and
paste the profile here now we will
update the department here and update it
as
content marketing
and click on the send button
here we can see that the profile has
been updated the department has been
updated to content marketing
so now
we would be declaring another function
that would be delete
for that we would be creating another
route for that would move to the main
dot co file
and the function main
will create another route
that would be delete profile
and the function name we would keep it
as daily profile only and the method
would be delete
now
we will declare the function delete
profile
we will copy the function that would be
update profile
and
paste it
and make the changes in that only
first would make the change in the name
that would be delete profile
now we will send the response
and we don't have anything to send it in
the response body
so
we will delete this
and we will send a 200 okay status so
we could confirm that the profile has
been deleted
so for that
we'll write
q dot
right header
and it would show us the status 200
and
to delete that
we will run a command
that would be profiles
equal to append
and inside the
circle brackets we would write
profiles
set colon
id coma
profiles
square brackets colon
id
plus one
and period period period
so now we will save the file
and move to postman
and test the delete function
now we will save the file and in the
terminal we will
enter the command control plus c to stop
the execution
now build the file again
and run the freshly built
executable file
now we'll move to postman
and
first we will
post the profiles as we have created the
executive file crash
now we have to click on the send button
as we can see that it has been sent to
the
request
body and we have
get the response
now
just run the get all profiles function
it is showing that it has quota profile
in the json format
we will post another profile
that would be of the department
sales
and it will be sales ad
so we have click on the send button
and the profile has been posted
now click on the
get
request and click on the send button
here we can see that there are two
profiles
in the json format
now
we will create a http request that would
be of the type delete
and copy the url
and paste it here
and it has the ids parameter
so we will
delete
the profile with id1
and click on the send
it is showing http header 200 as okay so
it has deleted that profile
move to get request
and click on the send button
here we can see
that we have only one profile left it
has deleted the profile
with the index zero
with that we have come to the end of
this session i hope it was interesting
and informative if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section below
also do subscribe to our channel and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you